brothers and sisters it is the winter
season in the UK today in my house my
boiler broke and the house was freezing
cold my kids are wearing jackets I'm
trying to find heating and as a father
I'm trying to make sure my kids my wife
are warm imagine the people around the
world I'm working with one om say 100%
donation policy charity who are helping
Syria Lebanon and Afghanistan people who
are freezing to death intense brothers
and sisters donate whatever you can
because today's experience with me
showed me Subhan Allah how vulnerable we
are and just made me remember those
people who are in need whatever you
donate guys even if it is1 help those
people in those countries alhamdulillah
brother and sisters um as you know I've
heard that um there's been some video
that has been circulating so I wanted to
get straight into it regarding our
brother a am brother uh ABD wahab
alhamdulillah and he does fantastic work
a soft brother looks big looks scary he
is but he is soft he is gentle
alhamdulillah I believe that he is soft
when needs to be soft harsh when needs
to be harsh and of course he's not free
from mistakes some benefits we can take
from this because we also know there are
people who are not qualified who are uh
who like to always attack du who are in
their bedroom you can see them they're
in their bedroom literally it's it's
their bedroom or their living room or
whatever room it is in their house
continuously um making videos and to me
they the last person should ever speak
you have no experience in the da n zero
and let alone being in the front lines
you was confronted once by a Christian
with a camera and then you just had to
run away or just like you didn't want to
be involved cuz you know it's not the
same being confronted Etc so you're no
one to speak on this matter please keep
that to yourself let's let allow people
who are I want to say experts but who
have some experience in the field who
deal with this on a day-to-day basis you
cannot talk about something that you are
not involved in in any way shape or form
please with all due respect so let's
watch this video in and let's see what
lessons we can take okay okay are you
running though oh no I I I just got into
Islam oh you just got into Islam okay
nice so when did that happen uh just
recently okay why you still got crossing
your NE yeah well I I kind of follow
both Allah the Messiah right oh okay I
don't know they they uh I was reading
there was a debate on Tik Tok they were
like is Jesus the Messiah or is he just
the Son of God or is he a prophet but it
says in the Quran it's like around uh
page 20 or something it says Allah the
Messiah no no it doesn't say yeah yeah
the translation yeah it's right here you
want I can probably pull it up yeah
Jesus is the Messiah actually I'm not
Andes
I was on my phone I don't know about no
no worries so so we inform you that
Allah is not the Messiah Allah sent the
Messiah Allah you get what saying cu the
thing is on this Earth if you see God
you're it's already over you get what
saying the whole idea is being tested by
God without seeing him cuz I do think I
cuz I called my dog Muhammad once and he
gave me like a weight what' you say are
you serious I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't know I didn't know I
didn't know get out here get out of here
you get knocked out what up [__] that's
it that's
it hey get out of here bro bounce
bounce beanie dude I got
you your yeah let's bounce let's bounce
bro let's
bounce you think you talking to bro hey
let's end the stream bro I'm going to
start cing all you're good you're
good guys you know what it is West Side
we in the building what's up so we saw
that for ourselves aldah so let's
dissect this one by one so you have an
individual who comes to the table I am W
ABAB you can very clearly see he is
totally polite totally like engaging you
know with body language you know fist
bumping all that kind of stuff um and
he's open to him he's trying to give him
out he's trying to understand where he's
coming from Etc it's all good now what
we need to understand is the following
somebody comes and uh says I called my
dog Muhammad
once yeah now you need to understand
something guys yeah we are in the uh
front lines people come and they say all
kinds of stuff they insult Us in
different ways I've had this in our da
table in Lester Square they come and
they try to provoke us there was one guy
who was literally pushing me literally
pushing me that had to I had to push him
back like he was literally forcefully
pushing me so and he didn't leave he was
there for hours trying to uh instigate
something Etc and I warned him I said do
not come near to my vicinity don't come
cuz you're you're acting you're
threatening me you know so these things
happen not only that I had an individual
who have come to my face with a B clava
telling me those people are going to cut
my ears Etc and I'll show you the
footage where I grabbed his mask why
because at the end of the day he was
there was an individual who was
brainwashed by the far right and he was
being indoctrinated and I was trying my
best to um you know um tell him to you
know not fall for the Trap Etc because
these people young people like that
individual so these things happen now
for us to be blameworthy it's like
basically telling us we're going to be
insulted sworn that this that and we
kind have moments where we have our if
for like you know the prophet mammad
peace be upon Him anyone will be upset
okay cuz the a a form of the an IM is
that the prophet peace told us in bukari
none of you will truly believe until you
love me Allah and his messenger more
than your own mother and father if
somebody insulted your mother and or
your wife or your daughter and you would
have a reaction why is it that when it's
the prophet Muhammad it's the the the
expectations have to be lowered why is
that number one now I don't I'm not
condoning violence and I don't I've
never actually G violent um I don't
remember like doing D for 10 11 years
but as human beings we can make mistakes
so he just grabbed him and pulled him
okay now obviously he just kind of fell
on the table but he didn't punch him Etc
and I don't know the laws in the UK and
I'm not asking anyone to do this my
point is the following that we know in
certain occasions where for example
let's talk about abuj the sahaba who in
the Battle of if I'm not mistaken he was
there and usually walking in arrogance
like Allah tells the Quran don't walk in
arrogance like can split the Earth he
was walking in arrogance now generally
we know walk in arrogance is a it can be
a form of it's a form of minor sh yes
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said Allah hates this walk
usually usually generally Allah hates
this walk except in this situation
except in this situation we also know in
the Quran inah fat the last Ayah that
Allah tells us Believers are those who
are harsh towards the disbelievers
Hostile ones and uh harsh towards them
and soft towards the Believers we also
know that the prophet peace be upon him
at a time when Abu Bak got so angry he
told some of the mush go and literally
this he said go and suck the clitorus of
Al I think for that matter now looking
at this context the only thing that I
can say to our brother Abdul wahab is it
is of course better like Allah says in
the Quran repel evil with that which is
good and the one that you have enmity
you will see friendship that's good but
again there are instances in the prophet
and in the Quran which it tells us to
deal with certain people in a certain
way again I am not I'm talking about if
somebody's you know being hostile
insulting I prefer people to come and
get the authorities Etc nobody should
get violent Etc yeah but he could you
know done it different my only issue was
that I would say um using foul language
like f his be I think this doesn't you
know and ABD he knows messag him on
whatsa as well it doesn't beit a Di and
he does I'll be honest with you I love
his da he doesn't get into debate I love
alhamdulillah you know so I would say
that didn't suit our brother
alhamdulillah yeah you know to say you
know F his beanie he was angry
understandable but we need to be careful
about this using the F language and this
that you know it doesn't suit our
brother just to be just in this matter
and also one thing I didn't like of the
other brother who was coming and see
Westside I think this is it's not a good
representative it's a little bit
childish in the ex you understand what
do you mean by west side and we here
doing da calling people the Islam what
what do you mean by west side or this
side you know I don't think that fit do
you get what I'm trying to say um and
even using the NW I understand in
America it might be a different context
but you know what's up mind whatever I
don't think these are things I
personally if it was me if somebody said
that I mean I would just say to him
listen mate get out of here just move
like move away from my table yeah I
would it's going to move away from me
but to now attack brother ABD wahab and
make it seem as as if he's done
something tremendously wrong I'm so
sorry the enemies of Islam are going to
attack Islam regardless yeah they would
probably say the peaceful religion look
Islam is not just about peace just let's
make this clear Islam is not just about
peace okay anyone that's been insulted
for that matter could have a specific
reaction anyone for that matter so we
need to be consistent if we went to the
Christians and agitated him and said oh
we believe in Jesus by the so we can't
we would never insult Jesus but if
imagine atheist came and said I called
my whatever whatever Jesus okay some
Christians will not tolerate that and
they will behave in a certain way and
this works with everybody all human
beings in all backgrounds whatever it is
you get what I'm trying to say so there
is nothing different but of course we
should be better but in this instance I
know how it is to be in the front lines
I know how it is cuz I deal with that so
I can relate to him it gets frustrating
and someone to insult the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who should be
more beloved to us than our own family
members you need to understand that is
there again I'm not asking for anyone to
have some kind of like use violence
always stick to the law again but to now
have unqualified individuals who are in
their bedroom or wherever who have never
in their life gone out to do d
um that we know of to come and now say
you know this Hadith and that Hadith
please yes we look at things
contextually we look at holistically you
can't pick up specific instances and be
like oh this and that oh once the one of
thef yes came and said oh Muhammad be
just and omab was going to do what is
that is that reaction abnormal was it
abnormal omab done yes he has a for the
but the prophet obviously had HMA and he
said look it's better not because people
are going to say um you uh we don't want
people to think that Muhammad kills his
people he's talking about killing
somebody okay nobody there was dying
being killed number one uh number two
about the companion who like you know
said that he was in war and they were
running away and this the example this
brother gave the one who attacks all the
D and backstabs people um oh he said
that he was going to kill he said oh I
believe and he killed him how is this an
example to this this is talking about
somebody dying you're killing somebody
because they you deem apparent it looks
like um they are lying no the prophet
said did you open this hard chest to see
if he was lying or not and he rebuked
him how is this a comparison to this
what the hell are you talking about bro
like what you talking about what's the
comparison to this so I would say in a
nutshell using foul language is to me
was the bigger issue here I'll be honest
with you yeah um grabbing somebody you
know and just just just grabbing them
again I don't know the laws in America
but yeah so I would I would just say
personally to be careful I'm not
condoning violence violence but uh the
video's gone viral and I'll be honest
with you people are going to attack is
regardless okay alhamdulillah Islam is
the fastest going religion and I would
just leave it at that guys in with
someone who's dealing with this in the
Frontline it is totally understable to
sometimes lose your call obviously not
in this manner maybe but to now have a
go at him and expect like him to be a a
a Flawless individual who someone's
insulting someone that you love so much
and not reacting a way where he just
grabbed him and pulled him yeah I think
uh we are um for those who are making
this seem as if this this was something
really really bad oh my gosh I'm so
sorry I'm not going to go down that
route you know and we ask Allah subhana
T to rectify the fs of our brother ABD
wab um and yeah you know it's it's like
that we've seen this with far when he's
been threatened Etc you know and I think
it's it's a right CA of action when
somebody's threaten you we're not we're
not pacifist we're not some like idiots
like we just yes see whatever you like
hit me on the head you know I'll turn
the other cheek sorry uh we don't follow
that okay and that's not even practical
yeah okay and our religion clearly
teaches us how to behave in certain
situations and the prophet you know you
know when it came to dealing with
individuals we know how we dealt with
them so that's all all I want to say
brother sister inah and hope this was a
fair take on the matter if not anything
I say bad is for myself andan anything
good is from Allah and his messenger
hope you guys benefited from this till
next time